so i applied for a pixar internship back
in high school i didn't get it maybe
maybe i should call him now hey i'm zach
king
and this is tick tock support
cheera racer asks how do i make good
tick content
that is a great question i am still
trying to figure that out but i don't
think about it from the platform
standpoint for me
i try to make it kind of evergreen when
my team and i are approaching a concept
maybe we're tackling a fear for example
which is everyone in the world has a
list of fears and so it's really
universal so i'll tap into those fears
and then write something that still
lands on a humorous side maybe has a
funny twist ending
they should work on any platform sexy
queen beezy
asks uh how do you edit your video clips
with which software
it's just awesome thank you appreciate
that there's a whole array of video
software that you can use it ranged from
what i started with with final cut pro
version 2 and all the way up into after
effects nuke there's a whole range
for us we use dozens and dozens it
depends on what the specific need is
one zacking video may have 12 different
softwares a whole dozen where it's like
you need something with cinema 4d or
you're using
maya it depends what each video concept
requires but my favorite videos are the
ones that don't actually require editing
they're the ones where
you actually take that post-production
and put it up front so what that looks
like is i made a camping video with my
kids
indoors and it was like how do you um
transition from
a camping tent inside your house into a
beautiful vista
view on a mountain range and we
accomplish that by
building a house set in a living room on
top of a mountain that's how you do it
and there's zero editing so
those are my favorite concepts where you
move the editing into the pre-production
fabio as what hardware and os are used
in vfx and animation studios i've been
curious about what the big fee effects
in animation studios like
ilm and digital domain and pixar and
disney use to create
the realistic and magical masterpieces
anybody here who could help
there are special softwares that
different studios use a lot of companies
have developed their own
internal softwares you have pixar that
use renderman
you have ilm that uses some of their own
stuff as well as i think they use nuke
when they get so niche they start
developing their own systems
because they have their own workflows
and needs and that way they can be
coding and updating especially in
animation
the different simulations that are
changing all the time so i applied for a
pixar internship
back in high school i didn't get it
maybe maybe i should call him now but i
always wanted to get my hands on render
man i was like how is pixar making
such photo realistic stuff it's
completely mind-blowing
require underscore h asks are there any
other apps that let you do quick video
editing similar to tick-tock
this might be a bummer to a lot of
people who think that i i use
tik-tok to edit i have never used stick
talk to edit they have some cool effects
um but i just don't personally use them
there are other apps i know i've used
light tricks and video leap those are
great apps and it's amazing what you can
do
like in the power of your pocket back
when i was saving up for final cut pro
this software that literally came in a
box this big you know it cost me like
twelve or thirteen hundred dollars
from the apple store to buy that and now
you have free apps like tick tock
um that you can just download and edit
it doesn't have like all the same power
but it's
pretty darn crazy at camera personae
asked do you think you could have done
a better de-aging job than what they did
in irishman i watched that film with my
wife on netflix
and for the first 20 minutes i i was
just like is this
is it makeup and i i didn't notice from
a vfx standpoint it didn't bother me at
all
and i know what that team did to create
the irishman effect what they did is
they filmed with three cameras and what
you do is you have the main hero camera
in the center
you have two witness cameras they're off
to the side and really all their purpose
of those two cameras is to capture data
the actors and the irishmen didn't want
to wear tracker marks martin scorsese
wanted to be natural
on set they didn't want to do green
screen you know like they do avatar with
the little
the tracker balls and looks like golf
ping pong balls all over them and
suits you know they want to be on set
and that's why you have these two
cameras on the side capturing all the
data for the face
so you can do the replacements i think
they did an incredible job at local
yikes says
i just found out i'm technically gen z
and i don't know how to handle this
should i download tick tock can i still
like avocado toast
send help if you're gen z and you don't
you're not in tik tok or you haven't
gotten it that's okay because you should
do what you like
if it's scrolling on tick tock then
awesome try it out for me
i love apps that give me a little
inspiration and tick tock's one of those
apps vine was one of those apps where i
go on
and i'll just like like or bookmark a
post if it gives me just a little
thought an idea
and what i enjoy about tiktok is when
you do that enough it starts to learn
you know pretty quickly and it feeds you
different videos based on that
so i've enjoyed my creative rabbit
trails that tiktok has led me down but
if you still haven't given avocado toast
to try
you do have to do that that is on the
list that's my saturday morning
breakfast
at hey it's clay says at tick tock us
how do you apply for the creator's fund
literally today the day i'm making this
video they just launched the creator
fund um i think you you have to have
over 10
000 followers and you have to have the
count for 30 days
you also have to have had a certain
amount of views i believe it's 10 000
views as well but uh
verify fact check that one for me not
many platforms have partner programs to
begin with
um you still have facebook and instagram
that are still
not quite you know helping the creators
out as much as they could
i hope the fun works out awesome i hope
it turns into a full-on partner program
for tick-tock
i think that's incredible for the
creator ecosystem i'm excited
at cruising control asks anyone on here
a tick-tock expert
maybe uh how do i trim a video in my
drafts it's out of sync with the audio
slash hashtag
i'm a boomer from vine days to tick-tock
i always have to upload back when it was
vine
there was a program workaround and you
had to like type a line of code or
something to upload it in this this
janky thing
with an ipod touch it only worked with
so i'll be honest i don't know how to do
this on
tick tock but if you take another
program let's take premiere or final cut
x for example
put it in your timeline and you'll move
over the audio just make sure you can
uncheck that layer
and move it over but there's also great
software now that'll sync it for you
this might be overkill for your problem
but you can look up a program like
pluraleyes
which just a click of a button basically
just syncs up all your audio i wish you
the best
at rank up official says i didn't know
editing videos was so difficult
we have a whole new respect for content
creators thank you you all deserve that
cash flow
oh cool thank you uh hey can anyone
throw us some advice finally someone
realizes how difficult it is to be a
content creator
so editing is very difficult i've been
editing for 15 years but one thing that
makes editing way better
is the better you're at planning the
better the shoot is the better
the edit it's magical in that you can
rearrange things however you want and if
something didn't work on set
that's great but the more that you're
planning especially for my videos where
it requires very little editing it's
because a lot of our thought
you know went into the pre-production
and the more time you're putting in
there and focusing and planning out
it actually cuts out of the editing time
significantly so
you know start your editing way up front
in pre-production
as far off ski asks can i edit my videos
on tick-tock i mean it's unprofessional
but hey tik-tok is actually a powerful
editing tool
i totally agree tik-tok is one of those
platforms like many others where
you're given the tools on your phone i
mean i think that's incredible power
and and what i love about it is that
anybody whether you're an eight-year-old
grandma
or a young kid you can go on and you can
get inspired to become hopeful maybe a
filmmaker maybe it's something that
gets you to be a dancer i don't know but
i love that there's tools on these apps
that are powerful but also getting
people to create
and i think that's the key and when you
and in the future we're going to see
some of the best apps are going to be
the ones that provide the tools for the
creators like a whole range of
really in-depth tools at ldusulfa
asks how does that king edit his video
so flawlessly i'm telling you the the
keys that are
completely worn off on my keyboard are
the right arrow left arrow because
we'll just sit me in my editing team
just sit and scrub between frames just
to make sure it's perfect
and massage the heck out of them it
takes hours and hours of just sitting
like focusing on each pixel that's how
they're flawless is just
the intense focus also not being afraid
to reshoot i'll shoot these videos
multiple times almost every single time
now because
it just there will be something off
they'll either be a different story beat
that we need to hit
or i didn't match my freeze it's as
simple as that
don't be afraid to fail and get back on
set and reshoot
at dxemers asks how do i upload to
tiktok and ig from my pc
i would want to say let me google that
for you but i do know the answer
you can go up to the right hand corner
you can click this little cloud
icon button at least for tick tock and
then hit upload i think instagrams is up
there too just make sure you're logged
in
hit that little cloud and then it'll
walk you through the upload process
at whoopergill asks does anyone know
what app slash website people use to
make old photos more clear
people on tick tock were using something
like ursly spring and i don't know what
it was i'm not familiar with these
softwares that you can use but i do know
if you have photoshop the
either mobile version or the version on
your desktop it's really powerful
software and for photos
you can go on there and just change and
filter and edit learn to do some
uh editing for those photos and for for
if you're doing video stuff you could
download a program like after effects
and just adjust the color
at it's vivieri asks uh i finally
download tiktok and
omg i'm overwhelmed how to use this app
let me answer that for you i felt a
little bit of the similarities when i
first logged on
all you have to do is go on that for you
page and just like what you like or hit
you know not interested or favorite
stuff and it'll actually rather quickly
it'll serve you
all the videos that thinks you'll enjoy
and you'll be on a bunch of happy rabbit
trails
at mooney alex asks how do i have almost
8 000 followers on tik tok
and then only get 18 views on a video i
posted 50 minutes ago
make it make sense okay this is a
different platform
uh the ratio of 8 000 followers to 18
views isn't terribly off but it's a
little low
um compared to a platform like youtube
or instagram what you notice about
tiktok is i have like 47
48 million followers and when i post a
video it might only get like a million
views in the first day
because they're they're gating it so
what what it's doing in the algorithm is
going through a process of saying
like small group of people what do they
think of it is it have high watch time
are people liking it engaging it sharing
it with a friend and then if it likes
that
it'll send it out to more people and
that algorithm will say oh it's working
really well
sending out to more it's a pro and a con
of tick tock it's a pro because
if you do have a video that gets through
those gates and it just it shoots it out
everywhere and you'll have you know 60
million views on that thing but it's
also a con because it doesn't feel like
it's going out to everyone right away
at laura rvk says my cat has 23k
followers on tick tock how do i monetize
this
all right i have some advice for you
laura don't monetize it yet i know as
tempting as it is and as as amazing as
000 followers is congratulations by the
way don't monetize it yet
you can actually turn this into a long
tail thing if you figure out your cat's
niche it may sound weird to a lot of
people but cats can have careers on the
internet take grumpy cat take erin's
animals there's tons of cats
that have internet personalities and and
make money doing it what i suggest is
grow the account and during that time
you know iterate on a ton of different
content and this is i'm assuming like if
you're interested in filmmaking or being
a content creator do this if not just
kind of let your cat live in fame or
maybe just do one brand deal with
what the heck might as well just sell
out but i recommend you don't
at michael online says zack king do you
create your own visual effects or do you
have help from your vfx team
how long does it create to make a post i
have a
large team that i work with some
in-house a big freelance team
and it's not just me doing the vfx
anymore it would be way too much work
for the amount of videos that we're
putting out
but i have to give massive thanks to my
vfx team and i also have to give massive
thanks to
you know my writing team but the
production team as well because again
they're also
pre-producing some of these in the front
end and a lot of them
don't require as much editing because we
can do that so it's a mix like i have
an amazing team around me that help make
these videos possible
how long does it take to create anywhere
from
two weeks to six months it's a massive
range it just depends
for example one of my videos was about a
miniature house i had a house this big
and a little mailbox this small
and the concept was i leave the house
and i walk over and i
take out the mail and i realize
everything's small and then i turn
around and the house is also small
and you're just like wait what's going
on and that video took us over a year to
make
mostly just of the logistics finding the
right lawn we needed
a lawn that had a certain grade it was
like an inch and a half grade every foot
that had to change
but also to have the right lighting that
took a year mostly for planning and then
we have same day videos where it's like
we'll actually film it on a phone
and just jump into an elaborate set that
can rotate and that's how
we're able to pull it off in a day in
that case i guess it's just
handy to say you have a room that can
rotate
at omg it's parker asked i'm confused
like
how do people even begin to do this they
got tick tock plus plus or something
okay julian bass i have to say is
really cool i think he's going to be a
really talented creator in the long run
if he sticks with
stuff on the internet i actually just
met him on dms after this video came out
and i remember he was trying to get the
attention of disney and he did that i
mean bob
iger retweeted the video or left a
comment saying this kid's going places
this is a great example of a tick tock
because it had like good music and it
felt
high energy but also it goes out to
props to julian and people like him
who are just expressive and are fun to
watch and you can tell
he's just got a good energy about him
and charisma
there's a little combination that make
good tick tocks like this
at john clay allen asks how are you guys
listing your original tick tock content
on your cvs
i don't know i don't i don't have i've
never made a resume other than the time
i applied to pixar
and that didn't get me anywhere so but
to be fair my work was pretty
pretty bad back then i think what john
might be hinting at and the question is
is your work getting you your next job
or how does how does that work always
make sure you're making your best
work you know you don't have to be a
perfectionist about it
but go really hard and part of that is
making sure you're you're filming stuff
or
i'm assuming you're filmmaker um you're
shooting or editing stuff that you
really love doing i love these
photographers for example on tiktok
who are showing their tutorial behind
the scenes process because simply
they're showing the behind the scenes
find clever ways to put that on tick
tock and showcase your talent
at hughtangclan95 asks how do i go viral
on tick tock i just want a taste
of my 15 minutes he's talking about the
15 minutes of fame
i i don't think you should be focusing
on going viral or becoming famous
the people i meet doing that are usually
making content that
isn't up to par uh for a long-term
career on the internet
here's a simple way people want to say
how do i find my passion look at the
stuff you're doing
from four in the afternoon when you're
out of work or five in the afternoon
till the evening maybe it's building
legos and you can share that with the
world actually there's a lot of creative
ways you could show your builds
i don't see why you can't do it on other
platforms like tick tock so
see prometum asked what equipment do you
use for night shoots
any special editing techniques there's
actually a couple reasons i don't do
night shoots
one it requires my cameras to have a lot
of light on set so i'm using
you know a couple different 3k lights
just to light up the scene
but then you're attracting bugs you're
getting mosquitoes in the frame and i
can't have that because i'd have to
remove them
each frame so that actually you'll look
in my content if you scrub through you
just notice it's all in the day
that's one of the reasons why but i've
done done one favorite video that was a
prison break it's like an escape
and using a fun silhouette of the giant
spotlight
and uh that was one of my favorite night
shoots that i've done
tina rae's asked anyone know what the
resolution is for tick-tock on editing
programs
so what i do to keep it the same for
tick-tock and instagram
i just do 1080 by 1920. it's the 1920 by
just opposite as far as what i'm
shooting in it changes it could be
8k 4k it could be 1920 by 1080
some sort of hd it could be on the phone
in the final export settings for tick
tock or instagram i keep it the same
it's just 1080 by 1920. that way based
on any phones that have different sizes
you know they can't they won't add to
the top but they will crunch it down
at jung gixxmani asks anyone in tiktok
know how to fix these issues when you
lip sync on audio and it uploads
unsynced
keeps happening to me that's got to be
annoying i'm sorry that's happening
i don't know what to tell you in terms
of the the tick tock program what i'd
recommend is taking it into a program
like
premiere or even even try imovie on your
phone or some
included app and just uh see if you can
separate the layers and move them around
at film mad finn asks quick things just
looking at vfx animation and editing
does anyone know
any free software that's really good to
learn on
that's a good question i'm not up to
date on what's currently the best
software that's free
i do know if you're into animation
blender's still out there and
we even use blender on the team here
that's one of the first 3d softwares i
ever used
because it was it was open software so
that means any developers can help
develop it and change the programming or
you can build a custom
you know built-in program for it but
it's great because it's free
and i love that in terms of vfx editing
i'm not sure what's out there but i do
know
it's really cheap to get like the adobe
cloud i'm not sponsored by them or
anything but i'm just saying like i
think it's
maybe student discounts 15 bucks or 20
bucks
um professionals like i think 30 bucks a
month so just uh
download adobe and give it a free trial
for 30 days see if you you like it
at sadkid rome asked i want to have an
editing skill
but zack king said it may take up to
eight years but worth it right
i've been now editing for 15 years and i
would say it's totally worth it if you
love it but editing is one of the things
that
you kind of have to have a personality
type where you're comfortable being
alone
and i enjoy just being in my office and
i could do it for 14 15 hours a day
i i love it that much so if you think
you you have that and you can just
just chill by yourself then you might be
a great editor the
infamous cpa asked serious question are
people just
super cold with video editing or does
tick-tock just have some dope features
or is it a combo of both
i think it is a combo of both the cool
thing about what tock does with its
editing features or its filters
and even duetting and being able to
share content within the app or like
make your version of that meme
that's really a power of tik tok now
what i do
is i just upload my videos and so that's
why i think there's a combo there's
creators making stuff
offline throwing it up and there's
creators recreating based off stuff on
tiktok and
doing it all within the app and i'd say
it's a combo
at daniel dunks asked how are people so
funny and creative
on tick tock i think one um people are
funny
can be funny on any platform but i love
that tiktok has created its own culture
for some of the humor that it does in
meme reviews and memes of memes and
duets on tick tock since the algorithm
is going crazy and sending all kinds of
new videos everywhere
i think it allows you to think a little
creatively and think like
oh i i don't need to have a limitation
here i'm just going to
try this and maybe it'll work maybe
people it'll resonate with people
so i think the app has freed up a lot of
creatives to try out different things
and that's what tic tocs got going for
it
so i hope that was helpful and you got
some answers for your tic toc questions
if you have more leave them down in the
comments and i'll see you next time
you